ils ont l'air paisible lorsqu'il se
repose mais c'est 15 éléphants sauvages
qui sont sur la route depuis la mi-avril
cause en fait toute une commotion en
chine parce qu'ils n'hésitent pas à
traverser les villages a pas de mots
j'avais peur nous sommes sortis et avons
vu un éléphant d'environ trois mètres de
haut un éléphant tous et même heurté à
notre mur avant de s'enfuir raconte
cette villageoise
le troupeau a déjà parcouru 500 km vers
le nord
ses pachydermes voyage à la manière d'un
groupe de rock star ils ont leur propre
personnel de sécurité et se font livrer
leurs repas c'est qu'avec une population
de seulement 300 bêtes les éléphants
d'asie sont une espèce protégée
les accompagnateurs sont là pour
s'assurer de leur sécurité mais aussi
pour éviter qu'ils ne fassent plus de
dommage car depuis le début de leur
périple les éléphants ont ravagé 56
hectares de cultures et causer
l'équivalent de plus d'un million de
dollars de dégâts
pour éviter qu'ils n'atteignent d'autres
villages des véhicules ont été déployés
pour bloquer des routes tango slow joe
combo dont les agents de police ont dit
qu'ils avaient besoin de camions pas
qu'on aura besoin de moi je resterais
ici explique ce camionneur les zoologues
ne comprennent pas ce qui a amené les
éléphants parcourir une si longue
distance mais il constate que depuis
plusieurs années ces bêtes ont tendance
à se rapprocher des villages c'est que
l'émergence de plantation de caoutchouc
les prive des plantes qu'ils mangent
habituellement dans leurs réserves
naturelles
d'ailleurs un autre troupeau est aussi
sorti de son habitat mais pour le moment
les dix éléphants se contentent de
rester dans une forêt de bambous sans
faire de dommage ils sélectionnent
révélé le radio canada montréal